a mysterious Story of Survival betrayal
and Desperation Yellowjackets was an
instant hit but what should we know
going into season two
season one of Yellowjackets premiered in
November 2021 and chronicled the events
of a devastating plane crash that left
the members of a woman's high school
soccer team stranded in the woods
without contact or rescue for 19 months
depicting the twin storylines of the
time immediately after the crash and the
lives of the tragedy's few survivors a
few decades later the show was quickly
met with critical Acclaim for those who
watched the show around the time that it
aired year long wait for a follow-up to
season one's intense Cliffhangers will
come to an end shortly yellowjacket
season 2 will premiere on streaming and
on demand for Showtime subscribers on
March 24th and will premiere on air on
March 26th while a long Year may have
passed since the finale premiered the
time fans have had to wait just means
they can expect season 2 to be the best
it can possibly be showrunner Ashley
Lyle told the wrap it's a deeply
serialized story and we wanted to make
sure we didn't rush it and that we got
it right and so this was the earliest we
could accomplish that
as the first season of Yellowjackets
comes to a conclusion we flash back to
the 90s and see that the teens are about
to face down a frigid winter in a
Canadian Forest jealousy hunger and
Madness are beginning to set in and we
know for a fact that season 2 will focus
on this dark and dangerous period
of this one for you if you
've stolen him speaking with variety
show runner Ashley Lyle confirmed the
show would be returning to the cold
Forest during this storyline viewers
will likely learn about the forces
stalking our protagonists why the forest
refuses to let them leave and how low
and desperate the behavior of the
freezing teammates becomes as the days
grow shorter as for the present day
timeline we're not exactly sure where
the show will go from there but it will
no doubt involve the murder of Adam
Martin the kidnapping of Natalie and the
return of Lottie one of the strongest
aspects of Yellowjackets is its
incredibly talented cast but who will be
coming back for season two well we know
that Melanie Linsky Christina Ricci
Juliet Lewis and Tawny Cypress are
returning to play the adult versions of
Shauna Misty Natalie and Taissa plus
Sophie nalis Samantha Hanratty Sophie
Thatcher and Jasmine Savoy Brown are all
coming back to play their respective
teenage counterparts we can also expect
to see Liv Houston as teenage van and
Courtney Eaton as young Lottie both of
whom have been made series regulars
however the big question remains will we
see their adult versions as it turns out
the answer is yes Lauren Ambrose of
servant and six feet under will play the
adult version of Van while Simone Kessel
of our flag means death and Obi-Wan
Kenobi will be starring as the antler
Queen herself Lottie Kevin Alves will
also be returning to play series regular
Travis you may also want to keep an eye
out for linsky's real-life husband Jason
Ritter also Nia sandea of truth be told
has been cast as Tina Kila replacing Kia
King variety reports that Nicole Maines
of Supergirl and Francois are node of
the Borgess have also joined the cast
Maines will be playing Lisa someone with
a connection to the adult version of
Lottie while our node will play coach
Scott's boyfriend
did you hear that Mom
dad God
oh my Furry Forest Friends I'm gay other
small roles we'll be seeing again
include Stephen Krueger as coach Ben
Scott and Warren Cole as Shauna's
husband however perhaps the biggest
casting news comes straight from Middle
Earth according to deadline Elijah Wood
has signed on for a season-long guest
Arc as a citizen detective alongside
Misty
the folks at Showtime seem to have taken
a if it ain't broke don't fix it
approach to yellowjacket season 2 by
bringing back the Warped Geniuses behind
the first season Ashley Lyle and Bart
Nickerson make up the dynamic duo who
created the visceral Survival series and
along with Jonathan lisko they were the
creatives running the show needless to
say their Twisted brainchild became a
Smash Hit earning all three Emmy
nominations and a place on season 2's
production team in fact Showtime was so
impressed with Lyle and Nickerson that
the company signed them to an overall
deal allowing them to work on new
Showtime series well we're excited to
see what new messed up projects they'll
cook up were mostly psyched to see the
original showrunners bring yellowjacket
season 2 to horrifying life
similar to most TV series The Individual
episodes of yellowjacket season 1 were
helmed by different directors some
standouts to work on the first season
include feature directors Eduardo
Sanchez and Daisy Von scherler Mayer as
well as Billy Woodruff who's worked on
numerous music videos with Joe and Tony
Braxton however perhaps the biggest get
for the show was Karen kusama who
directed the pilot and served as an
executive producer for the series kusama
excels intense films that play with
horrific Concepts like the invitation
and Jennifer's Body and that suspenseful
expertise is on Full display in the
pilot episode which opens with a
terrifying sequence where a young girl
runs for her life hunted by her former
teammates it's a gut punch of her first
episode and fortunately kusama is coming
back for season two speaking about the
new season she told the playlist season
1 in my opinion did a great job of
completely upending the idea of an
expected direction for any of it and so
I would just say that season 2 is a
continuation of that kind of surprise
and humor and tonal Collision that is
essentially as surprising and crazy as
real life
there is a whole lot going on in
Yellowjackets season one from Shauna's
pregnancy to lottie's cult to the
seemingly Supernatural forces lurking in
the forest and with two timelines to
follow you'll no doubt need a refresher
before season 2 is released so where can
you catch up on all the survivalist
horror well if you want to revisit
yellowjacket season 1 or check it out
for the first time you can do so by
visiting Showtime where you can watch
the series for the cost of a monthly
subscription
laughs